- Hallo!
- Was ist das denn?
- Abendessen.
- Das sehe ich.
- Wie war dein Tag, Tante Lisa?
- Gut, und wie war euer Tag?
- Super.
- Ich koche total gerne Gemüse.
- Ja, ich auch.
Du spielst sehr gut Flöte.
- Meine Ferienwoche:
Am Montag spiele ich mit
Tante Lisa draußen Fußball.
Am Dienstag gehe ich zum Musikkurs.
- Du gehst zum Musikkurs?
- Ja, manchmal …
Am Mittwoch wasche ich mit Opa das Auto.
Am Donnerstag räume ich mein Zimmer auf.
- Das glaube ich nicht!
- Am Freitag sehe ich fern.
Am Samstag stehe ich spät auf.
Am Sonntag …
- Am Sonntag koche ich mit Nico Paella.
- Au ja!
- Bist du fertig?
- Ja.
- Cool!
- Ich lese gleich noch ein Buch für die
Schule und dann gehe ich ins Bett.
- Ah.